good afternoon
good afternoon everybody
so first i wanted to read you the letter
from the president's physician updating
you on the president's health
president biden completed his first full
day of paxlevid last night his symptoms
have improved
he did mount a temperature yesterday
evening to 99.4 degrees fahrenheit which
responded favorably to tylenol his
temperature has remained normal since
then his symptoms remain characterized
as runny nose and fatigue with an
occasional
non-productive now loose cough his voice
is deeper this morning his pulse blood
pressure respiratory rate and oxygen
saturation remain entirely normal on
room air the president is tolerating
treatment well we will continue paxolvid
as planned his symptoms will be treated
supportively with oral hydration tylenol
and albuterol inhaler that he uses as
needed his eliquis and crestor are being
held during paxlovid treatment and for
several days after his last dose during
this time it is reasonable to add
low-dose aspirin as an alternative type
of blood thinner as i stated previously
the president is fully vaccinated and
twice boosted so i anticipate that he
will respond favorably as most maximally
protected patients do there has been
nothing in the course of his illness
thus far
which gives me
cause to alter the initial expectation
early use of paxlovit provides
additional protection against severe
disease he will isolate in accordance
with cdc recommendations and he will
continue to monitor him closely during
this very common outpatient treatment
regimen
as promised i will keep your office
updated with any changes in his
condition or treatment plan respectively
kevin c o'connor
so i also wanted to update you on what
the president has been up to and how
he's continuing to work hard on behalf
of the american people last night the
president signed the baby formula bill
congress passed he also spoke with
senator carper to see how he was feeling
and to the hosts of yesterday's dnc
event to thank them for their
flexibility this morning the president
received the president's daily briefing
virtually as you all know
he also met virtually with his economic
team on the progress being made to lower
gas prices for american families as you
all saw yourselves
dr zhai and i spoke to the president
over face time this afternoon
i asked him if he had a message for the
american people the president said he is
still he's still putting in eight plus
hours uh a work a day
and that he wants to remind americans to
get
vaccinated because in his own words it
matters
look the president hopes the country
will see that while we should continue
to take covet very seriously we have the
tools we need to deal with this
president biden is benefiting from two
vaccines two boosters and he's at
advocating for every american to take
advantage of these vaccines and boosters
which we have made available for free at
ninety thousand convenient places
nationwide and he's benefiting from
paxlovid a powerful antiviral we've made
available at forty two thousand
locations including local pharmacies
across the country
all americans have access to the same
vaccines boosters treatment that
president biden is receiving right here
at the white house and the president
hopes that all americans who are over 50
get boosted now if they haven't already
and get paxol bid if they test positive
now i'm glad to return to the briefing
room dr zha the white house coronavirus
response coordinator who is joining me
today and we're we're happy to take some
questions
i know you have a few things that you
wanted to share all right good afternoon
everybody i'm going to make a few
remarks some things
um
similar to corrine
first of all good to be with all of you
today
just
you just heard corrine give a an update
on the president
uh and i'm happy to
uh answer questions about his health in
a second we as as you heard we faced
time with the president earlier today i
also spoke at length multiple times
today with dr o'connor
and as you all saw just a few minutes
ago the president is doing better he
slept well last night
he ate his breakfast and lunch
i
fully
he actually showed me his plate
didn't ask about the menu but i did see
an empty plate with crumbs and
i have some guesses about what was there
but didn't ask
didn't ask i did ask him about his
appetite
he joked that his one regret was that
his appetite had not changed
um look he is he was he is in a very
good mood um
i want to take a step back and emphasize
the message that you heard from corinne
as the white house kobe 19 response
coordinator
what i think every american needs to
hear what the president laid out
is that while we have a very contagious
variant out there
thanks to this president's leadership we
have the ability to manage this
we are now at a point i believe
where we can prevent nearly every covet
death in america
that is a remarkable fact so if you are
vaccinated but have not gotten a booster
this is a really good time to go and get
a booster if you're over 50 and haven't
gotten a vaccine shot in the year 2022
this is a really go good time to go and
get a shot they are free they are widely
available
and as you heard if you are over the age
of 50 or have any kind of chronic
condition that meets cdc criteria please
consider getting treated if you have a
breakthrough infection
and if you don't have a regular doctor
you can go to cova.gov and find a test
retreat site near you
i also want to share some data about the
progress we are making both on vaccines
and treatments just over the last couple
of weeks over the last seven days
we've gotten 2.2 million more shots into
people's arms that's the highest we've
seen in a month
more than 900 000 americans have gotten
their
second booster shot in the last week
that's the highest number in six weeks
so as americans go about their daily
lives this summer they're heeding the
public health message and not just on
vaccinations by the way on treatments as
well
you know when i started in this role
about three three and a half months ago
we were seeing less than 4 000
prescriptions a day of packs of it
now pax levitt prescriptions are at
their highest level
last week
about 40 000 courses of paxolvid were
prescribed every single day across
america
it's a remarkable fact and if you think
about the fact that we have about 120
000 identified infections even if you
assume that some infections are not
getting identified because of home tests
it's a large proportion of people
getting packs of it i think that's
really good
it's preventing hospitalizations it's
preventing deaths every day
overall just so far in the month of july
920 000 americans have benefited from
pax of it
we have secured 20 20 million courses of
pax levitt that's the most in the world
by a lot
and again we've made it widely available
and of course free
all right let me finish by providing
what i think is really the bottom line
it's great to see the president doing
better
he's doing better because he is
vaccinated he is boosted he's getting
treatments
he is getting world-class treatment
exactly what you would expect for the
president of the united states
and the president has made clear to us
that it's incredibly important to him
and therefore is incredibly important to
all of us
that all americans have easy
free access to the same world-class
treatment that he's getting vaccinations
therapeutics so my message to my fellow
americans really is this please avail
yourself of this vaccine to build up
your immunity
please avail yourselves of treatments if
you qualify if you get infected and
let's continue to do everything we can
to prevent serious illness and death
from this pandemic all right thank you
very much for listening and i'm happy to
take questions as i know kjp is as well
i know the white house released his
elevated temperature level of 99.4
degrees can the white house provide
specific numbers on his oxygen levels
blood pressure levels beyond just saying
that they are normal would you be
willing to release that information you
know what i'll say is he gets his vital
signs checked several times a day
so of course
there are multiple numbers in there all
of his vitals including his temperature
i would argue but all of his vitals have
always been in the normal range his
heart rate his blood pressure his oxygen
level and his temperature the 99.4 was
the highest temperature he's had in the
last well 24 hours but i would say since
his diagnosis but he's had a normal
uh vital signs throughout the entire
course of the disease
by this point has the white house
identified all close contacts of the
president and do they go beyond i
believe the first lady the vice
president and ron claims so the white
house medical
the white house medical unit has
identified and informed 17 people
determined to be close contacts of the
president including members
of his senior staff
none of the staff members have tested
positive to date
and all of them are wearing masks around
other people per cdc guidelines
no members of the press have been
identified uh as close contact as well
and this uh this also includes the
member of congress that he uh traveled
with recently and i just want to triple
clarify the testing dates because if so
yesterday was day zero today's obviously
day one tuesday would be day five so
does that mean he won't be tested until
day six and if he's negative on
wednesday then he could resume in person
activities is that the timeline we
should be understanding yeah so we're
gonna obviously the cdc guidelines right
are five days of isolation he will do
that for those five days of isolation he
will be tested after he's completed his
five days of isolation and once he tests
negative
he will uh return to work but he be
first tested next on wednesday
yeah again i haven't done the math but
yes he's gonna do five full days of
isolation today's day one yesterday was
day zero
and he'll get tested after
day five
and then again the moment that he turns
negative you'll return to work you guys
both talked a lot about um obviously the
message from the president being get
vaccinated at this time but you also
mentioned just how extremely contagious
this variant is so why not do additional
mitigation encouraging additional
mitigation measures like mass growing
indoors or other
um
in general yeah yeah absolutely and i
have like i did a covet briefing about a
week ago in which we laid out our
two-prong strategy i actually think i
did it yesterday where i said two-prong
strategy one to prevent serious illness
one to prevent infections so in terms of
mitigation uh very very clear cdc
guidelines on this very clear
if you're in one of the orange zones
people indoor spaces should be wearing a
mask it's a great way to prevent getting
infected it's a great way of preventing
spread
another important mitigation measure is
using regular testing
the president obviously gets tested
regularly many of us get tested
regularly
we have made
we've sent out 560 million tests i
believe if that number is right i think
it's 560 million deaths to americans
directly for free from kovites.gov
people can go and get tests tests have
become cheaper you can get it through
your health insurance we think regular
testing is another important mitigation
measure and then we're doing a whole
series of work on trying to improve
indoor air quality improving ventilation
filtration so we are doing a lot on
mitigation and we talk about it i'm
talking about it now um but you know
when we're talking about the president
who is now infected the key is is to
also remind people
that we have a very contagious variant
people will get infected our absolute
priority is making sure that when people
get infected
they don't get seriously ill
thanks uh dr ja how frequently is the
president being examined by a physician
in person
well so the president's being i mean
people are interacting with the
president all day um through zoom and
stuff dr o'connor has been seeing him on
a regular basis i think i don't have a
exact number of times that he saw him
yesterday or today but
multiple times a day
either by phone call by zoom physically
examining him
but the president's doing really well so
he doesn't need an ongoing you know exam
all the time and uh and obviously he's
getting examined at least once a day but
dr o'connor is interacting with the
president on a regular basis has the
president been examined by any other
physicians beyond dr o'connor
physically examined i mean i've spoken
to him by facetime not that i know of
not that i know of was there a
discussion about the possibility that
eliminating the blood thinner even for
just five days would increase the risk
of stroke because he's on chronicle
atrial fibrillation yeah so we by the
way clinically do this a lot i can't
remember probably thousands of patients
that i have taken care of over the years
in the hospital who come in who need a
procedure
who are on blood thinners like eliquist
uh or other blood thinner so we stop for
short periods of time where people get
procedures or we they stop it because
he's obviously stopped it because he's
on pax of it
for atrial fibrillation we think it's a
relatively low risk thing to do
but dr o'connor uh as was part of the
plan has been consulting with experts
around the country uh and based on input
that he got he made the decision to give
the president a short course of aspirin
during that time this was a discussion
that took place whether or not to go
with pax levitt over say a monoclonal
antibody you know that decision was made
by dr o'connor um it packs a bit is the
first line agent that that we recommend
that was a decision that dr o'connor
made and then we know that you have to
look at somebody's medication list and
determine do you have to make
modifications dr connor made the
decision to uh stop these two medicines
i talked about those are very reasonable
we uh that's what all the specialty
societies recommend uh that that they be
paused and so then he dr o'connor made
the decision to add aspirin for a short
period of time
dr o'connor also said that the
president's using an inhaler as needed
does he regularly use an albuterol
inhaler or is this something that was
prescribed just to deal with the cloven
symptoms yeah so as all i think all of
you know because it's been disclosed for
years the president used to have asthma
he has what people talk about is
reactive airway disease which is
people often when they have a viral
syndrome or when they some people get it
when they go out in the cold or some
people get it when they exercise can get
a little bit of of bronchospasm and an
or cough the way to treat it is with an
inhaler so the president his last time
he used it before this illness was when
he had a cold i think last fall at some
point
during that cold he also had a little
bit of cough that that comes with viral
syndromes and used it so he does not use
it on a regular basis it's not part of
his regular medications but in the
context of a viral
crediting the president's boosters for
part of the reason that his symptoms are
so mild
should all americans regardless of age
be eligible for that second booster and
if so what's the delay here yeah so the
fda is very clear on this and we follow
fda scientists and their guidelines on
this people over 50 um if it's been at
least five months should get that second
booster i've been very vocal in my
advocacy i think the evidence there is
overwhelmingly clear
the date on on people under 50 that's
something the fda is is continuing to
examine they have not made a
determination that that is something
that is warranted
and we really do follow the fda
guidelines on these things authorization
thank you very much doctor
the cdc says that one-third of americans
still haven't been fully vaccinated and
you mentioned i think mr new york times
that congress still hasn't allocated
enough funding
for boosters into the fall what is your
message to congress if they don't
allocate funding for boosters in the
fall and also what's your message to
americans who still refuse to get
vaccinated and i have another question
after that yeah so let's start with
talking to americans i think what we're
seeing
uh
across the country is
uh there are a lot of infections but
when when people are vaccinated and
boosted they tend to have a far less
serious illness
this virus is going to be with us
forever uh it's really really important
that people build up their immunity
against this virus and so i've been very
clear for years i mean
two years or a year and a half i guess
since we've had vaccines uh that getting
vaccinated is one of the best ways that
people have to protect themselves to
congress you know what i would say is
congress has been a great partner uh to
this administration in terms of funding
the coveted response making sure that
vaccines and therapeutics are widely
available
and that's one of the reasons we have
plenty of vaccines right now but the
problem is that we need to continue this
effort the reason we have seen so much
progress
is because we've had the resources to do
the things that are necessary for the
american people
and if we take our foot off the gas and
stop you know all this work that we are
doing
um we will slide backwards
and we do not want that
and
we can do a lot in the administration
but we need funding to do all those
things and congress
is the part of our government that
allocates funding so
my message to congress is it's really
important to continue to protect the
american people as we get into the fall
and winter we will need more resources
we need the resources now to prepare for
the fall and winter and it's really
important that congress step up and do
its part so anyway the
dr rochelle wolinski says that we're
kind of headed toward a new normal um
with covid
and currently cbc says that 41 thousand
americans are now hospitalized still in
480 deaths a day
are dying from this disease
what does a new normal mean and what is
an acceptable number of deaths yeah um
so let me say two things first of all
we're clearly in a much better place
than where we were
you have to have two there are two sets
of things that we have to be able to
things that sound contradictory but
actually we have to keep in our heads at
the same time one is we're in much much
better place than where we were 18
months ago when the president took
office deaths are down 90
400 300 400 480 deaths a day totally
unacceptable i mean at 400 deaths a day
that's like 130 000 deaths a year
that's like three times worse than a bad
flu season that is not acceptable should
not be acceptable certainly is not
acceptable to this administration
um and that is why we are here every day
and
working and trying to um
inform americans that the best way to
reduce that number the best way to make
sure that fewer people die fewer people
get hospitalized is to make sure people
have built up their immunity through
vaccines and that people get treated
when they have breakthrough infections
um first for you dr john that i want for
you for too korean um so on bringing him
down from the eliquis a number of
physicians have suggested that having
the dosage might also be
or might be a preferable option could
you talk a little bit about why that
course wasn't taken yeah there are
several different ways of doing this um
what i know is that i spoke to dr
o'connor he
has consulted uh and again we had a plan
that you know uh dr o'connor had a plan
uh to consult uh experts at walter reed
at gw elsewhere he's done those
consultations and based on that input
that dr o'connor made the decision
uh to stop it for
uh
five plus days and and um and then start
aspiring and just sorry just just to
clarify and and he has started the
aspirin course or that was just
something that was recommended he has
started the aspiring course as i
understand it
um i didn't hear um in your introductory
marks a look ahead to next week and i'm
just curious if you're if you have
anything if the if this is going to
delay the the she meeting for example
where are we on that
so as far as president xi uh i don't
have anything to share on that i know
the president spoke to that a couple
days ago
and he his words was he's expected to
speak to him in with the next 10 days
nothing again nothing on his schedule to
share at this time look when it comes to
uh when it comes to president xi we have
kept open communications with china as
we have stated many times before on
staff level the president last spoke to
him in march i don't have anything more
to add on that uh and you know
when it comes to schedule we'll we'll
see how the president does he's
improving which we all should be uh
thrilled that the president of the
united states is doing better according
to dr o'connor
that is good news and we welcome that
good news and we continue to uh to wish
him well
creator the chances of serious
complications behind the president now
can we at least speak to that
yeah you know um what i would say is
he's being he's continued to be
monitored very very closely um
uh it's obviously day this is day one
but it's his second day that uh since
his ident infection was uh identified
i'm really happy to see that he is
getting better and we will continue
monitoring very closely uh until he is
uh until he tests negative and so
serious complications i think the the
the chances of serious complications for
this president have been dramatically
reduced by building up of his immunity
and getting him anti-viral drugs the
things that really make a huge
difference in lowering his risk
um and
and that's i think the most important
part of this
um we'll continue monitoring him i'm you
know and we'll see how he does over the
next few days
i just wanted to add as far as a
schedule and events look the president
was very active today he had said he's
working eight plus hours a day and that
is uh he's still doing the job of the
president so that does not end
and we have put out photos and videos
you guys heard from him directly so i
just wanted to add that as as you're
asking about um you know his schedule
okay just a quick follow-up to mary's
question about the inhaler has the
president used an inhaler since testing
positive for covet or was dr o'connor
just saying if he needs it he will use
it going forward yeah um what i
understand is that he has used it a
couple of times in the last uh since
testing positive um you know he's got as
you may have heard he's got a cough and
i mentioned this yesterday it's in his
in the dr o'connor's note oftentimes
when people get viral syndromes and they
get a cough uh
taking an inhaler can be helpful so he's
thinking the inhaler was not noted in
his last physical right
it's not a regular medicine that he uses
right he really only uses it
intermittently
um
largely when he gets viral viral
syndrome so he gets colds basically and
so uh so it's not a regular medicine
that he uses on an ongoing basis the
other question i have to be dr
vice president harris is a close contact
with the presidents and the cdc guidance
says that if you're close contact you
want to wear a well-fitting mask when
you're around other people she just
spoke at a conference in dc and she
hugged someone without a mask on she was
also maskless for most of that
conversation would you have recommended
that she keep her mask on given that
that is the cdc guidance
you know i i think i i i'm not sure what
i've not been tracking the vice
president's activities i so i don't have
anything specific to say about
uh what she did my understanding is that
the vice president is following cdc
guidelines on close contact she's also
uh recently been infected so within the
90 days
uh of a previous infection but i don't
know if you have anything else to offer
on vice president i guess she isn't
following the cdc guidance bill right if
she is hugging someone without a mask on
[Music]
i just wanted your clarification on that
yeah i think the cdc guidance is clear
but i you know the problem is me
commenting on what the vice president
did when i wasn't actually i haven't
seen it or i don't actually know what
happened is very very difficult so i'm
going to
ask you and she embraced someone you
don't have to see it i mean that's
that's what happened
yeah so usually when we think about
people having contact is for an extended
period of time
i don't again i didn't see the hug i
don't know how long about hog lasted
but it's very hard for me to comment on
something i really didn't see so
and corrine um the president had said
that he was going to receive a report on
monkey pox today is that happening what
is the report do you
know i don't know where that report is i
i know there is a report that has been
written for the president uh whether the
president has had a chance to see it yet
today i don't know so it's an internal
report that he will be receiving from
his advisers yes will that be made
public or
i don't i i don't know which
i mean president guest lasso reports
from his advisors um i don't know which
ones uh are
get made public it's just an update on
the status of monkey thoughts yeah i
would just look at that as an update to
the president on what we have been doing
and responding to the monkey pox i it's
not a a report to to share out it's
something for the president which he
gets very often just to get a sense of
the work that we're doing on an issue so
that's what again just clarify a couple
details for accuracy and reporting you
said of the 17 closed contacts one of
them is a member of congress is that no
i was saying it includes the members of
congress i do not have the specific of
of uh each person but you wouldn't be
able to detail without identifying them
we just want to be privacy is incredibly
important here uh
i would yeah i would reach out to them
directly what i'm saying is we've we've
contacted 17 people within those 17
people their senior staff within those
17 people it also includes members of
congress and as of as to date
no one has as today as far as we know no
one has tested positive and then i guess
not specific to those close contacts but
can you tell us is there anybody else on
the white house campus right now who has
tested positive
this so out of abundance of privacy to
protect to protect people's privacy our
protocol is to only share if someone has
had
close contact to the president uh and
the and the four principles that is just
our protocol we have to we have to keep
people's privacy here and that is
incredibly important and we respect that
so just for clarity even if without
identifying names we can't do it again
i'm not going to i'm not going to share
private information or private uh detail
on anybody i want to get your reaction
to steve bannon but while we're on this
topic can i ask you dr john very quickly
we don't know what this is but there
could be earlier indications of what
type of sub-variant it is you said it
could happen within less than a week
just for the sake and i know it's a bit
of a hypothetical but over the weekend
we may learn some more details may not
see you
ba five which is the most dominant
sub-variant right now is that one that
after you get that you could be more
inclined to get another one within a
smaller period of time in other words
someone who got something recently is
that one they're more eligible or more
able to get can you help people better
understand who are concerned about it
yeah absolutely so ba 5 is the most
immune invasive variant we've seen and
what that means is that if you were
infected three months ago
um four months ago
your protection against getting
reinfected with ba5 is much lower if you
were vaccinated five six months ago you
have a much higher risk of getting a
breakthrough infection if you're
infected with ba5 what that means for
future immunity none of us know right
now because it's ba five has just become
dominant it's the primary so we don't
know what the implications are and we
obviously don't know what uh variant or
sub-variant the president was in fact i
guess i should ask if you just had it a
month ago three months ago i recognized
it's lower but for someone who had it a
month ago if it's immune
immunity invasive does that mean you
could get it within a month of having
that another case so in so depends on
what you had a month ago right and if it
was ba five wasn't dominant then but it
was still present obviously if you had
ba 5 a month ago then you're much less
likely to be able to get ba 5 now
so it just depends we have seen
occasionally people getting infected
within that 90 days but it is still
relatively uncommon thanks did you have
any reps for the steve bannon case i
know it's over and i know obviously
what did you just say
which was the last part i missed the
joke
well i was just saying we can tell you
wanted to address that
so look
i'm not going to comment specifically on
that case but obviously everyone should
cooperate with the january 6 committee
our administration has been made very
clear this president finds this what the
select committee is doing to january 6
committee is doing uh very important and
people
should be you know listening and
learning from what happened on that very
dark day
and this is very important committee
where they're working to get to
the bottom of what happened on that day
it was uh an attack not just on our
democracy but also an attack on our law
enforcement and again i'm not going to
comment on that specifically but yes
people should obviously should cooperate
with the committee
good thanks great uh dr chad are there
any other medications that the president
is prescribed that he occasionally takes
that do not appear on his 2021 health
summary yeah not that i'm aware of
and then why are we not hearing from dr
o'connor on this i understand that
you've
released statements from him
um but yesterday we had a difficult time
uh comparing the description of the
symptom progression from dr o'connor's
letter versus how you all laid it out in
the briefing room and then dr zha you
did some interviews this morning but
your last update from the president was
at 10 o'clock the night before well
a couple of hours ago right at 11
o'clock you got a detailed letter uh
from dr o'connor you we
we've given you two uh detailed letters
from dr o'connor and you've heard
directly from here from him
look
we
we
yes you have you've heard from the
letter that is hearing directly from him
we're not playing telephone here you're
hearing directly uh from the from the
physician yes it is i mean that's that
is hearing directly uh from in his words
in his words you are hearing directly
from dr o'connor as i read out but i'm
answering your colleagues question here
so
give me the second to do that thank you
um so you've heard directly from him um
and not only that you have heard more i
would argue easily argue about a mild
a mild symptoms
of a virus than any other president
we have we have dr jean and i were here
for an hour fielding questions we're
here today
answering questions we are going to
commit uh to making sure you're hearing
uh from dr o'connor from his daily
report detailed uh report
from dr o'connor and here here's the
thing uh dr ja is one of the foremost
expert in this in this field when it
comes to to covet uh he also has dealt
with covet patience he clearly is
running our coveted
response and is a medical doctor and he
knows how uh this process works and
again we should feel good and be uh very
uh
happy that the president is doing better
that he is improving uh this is the
president of the united states he's
improving he's reacting well to the
treatments
and let's not forget we have the tools
to to treat this because of the work
that this president has done
you're making that you know the
president's improving that dr shah is a
medical doctor obviously a lot of
experienced copic response unit but when
we've got questions about uh you know
his symptoms
progressing he had a fever last night
his cough is now loose as opposed to dry
and so he didn't he did not have a fever
last night just to make that clear i
think dr jean made that very clear
99.4 is not a fever it's not even a low
grade fever so he did not have a fever
last night
he treated it he gave tylenol and i
should actually let dr zha speak to this
more because he is the medical doctor
which is why he's joining me today at
the briefing room he gave he gave the
tylenol for discomfort which is not
unusual if you have cove many of you
have had covet we would argue that if we
probably take the temperature of some
people here they might have a 99.4 uh
degree fahrenheit temperature that is
not uncommon but i would let dr shaw
speak to that more
let me let me just talk about the
dr o'connor and so you you've heard
directly from him as corinne said in
terms of the the notes that he writes
every morning
um
he and i he and dr fauci
all of us talk multiple times during the
day
dr fauci is president's chief medical
advisor and obviously one of the
foremost experts uh on infectious
diseases we speak very regularly i've
been connecting speaking every day with
the president
today by facetime
and you're getting updates sort of about
twice a day
right
you got one yesterday at this time early
this morning you got an update about how
he was through last night i was on tv at
6 40 in the morning
did not think it was appropriate for me
to call the president at 6 20
wake him up and say you know how are you
feeling i think he'd be like probably
would tell me that he would be feeling
better if i hadn't called and woken him
so
um but you know obviously he was seen
early this morning he was examined and
then immediately we put out information
about the president's uh status
overnight i'm now here to give you more
information about that the point is like
we're giving you information
on a very very regular basis
and we're doing it as a team uh with all
of us so when you've described when his
letter has described his 99.4 degree
non-fever as
being treated with tylenol and now we're
hearing from you that he was treated for
discomfort that's an inconsistency yeah
so i'll have to pull up the letter but
what i understand and spoke to dr
o'connor spoke to the president
um
and those of you who know hundred-point
force i've been taking care of patients
for twenty some odd years hundred point
four is what we consider a low grade
fever hundred and one point five so we
consider a uh a regular fever 99.4 is
very much within the normal range um
most people are between 97 and 99 people
tend to have slightly higher
temperatures later in the day and into
the evening this is often why we see
fevers often come up for people who
actually have fever uh in the evening
um
told you yesterday the patient was a
patient well the patient
the president um
uh was feeling tired uh and he just
didn't feel as great yesterday feels
much better today by the way
and for anybody who's ever had a viral
syndrome i assume many of you have had a
cold in your life
many of you have had coveted and you
might might have had a flu
when you just don't feel great taking
tylenol helps you feel better
and so dr o'connor gave him some tylenol
early in the evening
and but noted because his temperature
was 99.4 he just noted the temperature
was 99.4 that was the highest
temperature the president's had in the
last 24 hours or since he uh was found
to be infected um and uh and so he noted
that as a as a part of
uh of of his treatments but the
president has had no fevers 99.4 is the
highest temperature the president's had
so far
and the president is continuing to do
better and feel better
do these briefings today the weekend i
already spoke to that um
as
actually i may not have spoken to that
um
i it's i'm excited to hear that you guys
want to hang out with us over the
as possible weekend
okay
um
look we are going to continue in all
seriousness we're going to continue to
provide
updates from
the president's physician as we have
detailed report as you guys have been
receiving uh and uh and we'll see you
guys on monday we're not gonna be here
over the weekend but we will be
communicating as we have been the last
24 24 hours ago or see him newly every
day
i can't i can't promise anything right
now or commit to any any uh any uh
specific
status if there's any change again
you're going to get a daily report from
the president every day and so that will
provide any information
about his health but
i just want to reiterate this the
president is improving he has very mild
symptoms
of
a virus
and
and we should be
thrilled that the president of the
united states is doing better uh and
again it's because of the treatments
would well
you're that's the wrong administration
you're asking the wrong demonstration
that question uh
but again you know we have the tools uh
and that's why we're able to give him
the treatment and also you know this is
what the president has been working on
for the past year and a half to make
sure that the treatment that he's
getting others can so again folks could
get should get vaccinated if they have
it and they should get boosted uh as
well we're going to continue go ahead
thanks speaking of this weekend are you
aware of any plans to schedule
events briefings meetings for the
president while he's in isolation or is
the expectation he'll just watch tv
well it's a similar question that i just
got
right now we're going to what we commit
to is making sure you all hear
a detailed report from the president's
physician if we have more information we
will share that with all of the implants
for him to engage in activities or
anything like that again if we have more
to share we will share that i don't have
anything right here at the podium to
share to share with you it's about other
than for example the official
photographer or videographer who else is
actually in the room with the president
is he being staffed is the chief of
staff actually in the room with him or
anyone else so uh all primarily all of
his meetings have been virtual you saw
one meeting just moments ago right
before we started this briefing with his
economic team uh you all had an
opportunity to to go into the south
court auditorium to hear directly from
the president
so primarily all of his uh meetings have
been virtual he is following cdc guide
guidance when it comes to a very very
very small footprint
around him as you saw the the
videographer the photographer
was with him they were
socially distanced at six feet they wore
n95 masks we are making sure that we
keep two he is making sure that he is
isolating and keeping to the cdc
diabetes so just as far as you know just
the videographer the photographer small
footprint a very small footprint i don't
have a list for you at this time but a
very small footprint he is
indeed adhering to the cdc guidelines
following up on jackie's question can we
just clarify for the record the timeline
of the president's illness
dr o'connor's letter the first letter
yesterday said that symptoms or at least
the cough started wednesday evening then
the briefing dr yesterday you said he
wasn't symptomatic until thursday
morning so can we just get it when did
symptoms actually start
and i spoke to the president i asked him
directly
on wednesday evening
two evenings ago
felt fine all day felt fine in the
evening the only thing he said he felt
before he went to bed was he felt tired
he had so he did not have a cough did
not have any other symptoms on wednesday
night
now whether that tiredness is part of
kovid or whether he had just had a long
day he had been standing outside in 95
degree temperatures speaking um again i
sometimes look at the president's
schedule and i get tired looking at his
schedule um so uh we don't know but he
felt a little tired he he went to bed
and then he said he had a sort of a
restless night just didn't sleep well i
woke up multiple times
again is that a coveted symptom
but it's hard to say right i mean people
have restless nights they have they're
tired before they go to bed
the next morning
he was
he got tested as part of his routine
testing what dr o'connor described to me
was he asks questions like how you doing
how are you feeling
as the anagen test came back positive
uh he began to probe more obviously as
the pcr test was being done are you
really feeling okay
and the president said well i sort of
sort of do feel like i had this bit of a
runny nose and a little bit of a of a
cough and those things the presence that
he really been aware of just that in the
morning around that time
that's what dr o'connor described to me
that's what the president described to
me as as timeline
and um
and that's how i understand the symptom
progression kareem two of the events
that those presidents have to pull down
for now are political ones there was the
fundraiser in philadelphia dnc event in
florida um
is he concerned at all about you know
one of the things he wanted to do moving
forward was really start drawing this
contrast message republicans ahead of
the midterms i know he's working a lot
remotely but is he worried at all about
the
political piece of his job suffering
right now no he's not worried he's going
to continue to do the work uh that that
you've seen him do
he's going to he's also making phone
calls he's having these virtual
meetings that we have provided
but you know this is uh this is a
as we know covet is is not unusual right
this is something that we were prepared
we were preparing for uh this there is
treatment right there are tools uh to
make sure that uh uh we all you know we
all are able to deal with covet in in
this current time um and uh and you know
and we'll continue to move forward on
that but he's not he's not concerned
but these are two questions for doctor
what precisely is the president's most
recent blood oxygen level you called it
normal but that's a little vague i
wonder if you could put more specificity
on that so he gets his ox he gets all of
his vitals checked several times a day
um
and what i will say is
he's not short of breath he's breathing
fine he's obviously on room air his
oxygen levels have consistently been
consistently been in the normal range
um throughout the entire 36 or whatever
number of hours since he's tested
positive
um there have been no concerns right on
his oxygen level he feels fine he's not
obviously he's been on roommate the
whole time hasn't fell short of breath
his auction levels up in normal
um what the normal range is i mean i
think you look up
um he look i i i what i will say is that
there's never been any concern about his
oxygen his oxygen levels have always
been normal throughout the whole
time that he's been infected and getting
tested just one more follow-up and when
do you expect that you will have
identified which variant has impacted
the president it's a very good question
as i think i mentioned yesterday
typically takes about a week
to do genetic sequencing um as i said
this this virus is going to get a little
bit of special treatment because this is
the president so we know it's going to
get expedited usually takes a week
because hey there's some time in actual
sequencing um but this is going to you
know they're going to sort of prioritize
getting this sequence so i don't i don't
actually have a a date and a time that
i'm expecting it my assumption is it's
going to be faster than a week
but we will see my hope is early next
week sometime
thanks karine just uh
jumping on steve's question i just wanna
be clear you're saying primarily the
meetings have been virtually other
people can be in a room on a virtual
meeting i just want to be clear are you
saying that ron clayne nor any other
officials top officials have been in the
room with president
from my understanding uh the meetings
that he has had with his top of the
officials have been virtually does that
mean no other officials in the room with
him though that's my that is my
understanding
and if i could just ask about the
january 6 hearings uh do you know if the
president had a chance to to watch them
did any reaction uh regarding the
hearings last night and also uh our new
standings with he was planning to
address them
obviously that's not gonna happen in the
next couple days
but is there a plan to address the
january 6 hearings in the near future
there's no plan at this time for the
president uh to address the hearing i
can tell you that i spoke i asked the
president if he was able to
uh to watch the hearings last night he
told me he caught some of it the
beginning
of the hearings
and i will say what we have said and
reiterate what we have said many times
the president believes uh that the it
was a very dark day in our time in our
in our in our history in our democracy
when we saw the attack that was uh that
happened
at the capitol when we saw the attack uh
on our law enforcement and he believes
that he supports the january six
committee he believes that they're doing
important work uh and he really believes
that the american people should be
watching and paying attention i know
that was their last hearing last night
but he did he was able to catch some of
it on the part that he caught last night
did he share anything about those
specific those specific parts any of the
thoughts about how he didn't share
specific parts i did not ask him i just
asked if he was it was able to uh catch
some of the hearing last night
uh thank you um couple clarifying
questions um i know you said that his uh
report even dr o'connor said after
citing his temperature of 99.4 degrees
said after tylenol his quote his
temperatures remain normal since then
now you said the numbers have ranged a
little bit but can we just have the most
updated number the most updated
temperature from today
that the president was experiencing
like what was what temperature did you
record this morning um i don't know that
um what i will say is that his
temperatures have always been in the
normal range again he's getting his
vitals checked several times a day
the highest temperatures he's had
uh so far is 99.4 that was the
temperature from last evening
which again uh in my 20 plus years of
clinical experience i would never call
an elevated temperature
certainly not a fever
and
and all of his vital signs heart rate
blood pressure oxygen temperature have
all been in the normal range every time
he's had them
99.4 isn't considered a fever based off
cdc guidance but
the dr o'connor still said his
temperature has remained normal since
then since he recorded 99.4 degree
temperature so
if
if he's saying since normal since then
that would indicate that it was not in
the normal range how how did he describe
it yeah yeah so i i've i talked to dr
o'connor about this and uh not did not i
mean basically about about the president
um
often in clinical practice especially
when you have somebody who's infected
and you're reporting on that person you
often report that person's highest
temperature we call it the t max or
maximum temperature of the last 24 hours
and that is what dr o'connor was doing
in the in that moment he was reporting
the highest temperature that the
president has had
which turns out to be in the normal
range so his highest temperature in the
last 24 hours or since he got infected
or since he's been known to be infected
has been 99.4 and has remained has
remained in the normal range so you can
read that in two different ways if we
try to parse it it was in the normal
range it has remained in the normal
range since then
look we can try to parse out the words
the bottom line is
president's doing better
his vitals are normal you all saw him
his appetite is good
he's doing pretty well
right thank goodness and by the way
right because he is
we're all thrilled i suspect you're all
thrilled i know the american people are
relieved this is all good
and the president is doing better he's
obviously going to be continued to be
monitored he's going to remain in
isolation we'll you know he'll get
tested once he's done it with his
isolation period
but
the big picture point here is the
president's doing better today than he
was yesterday and yesterday he had mild
symptoms today's feeling even a little
bit better he's doing well
just i understand there's been questions
about dr o'connor but does the white
house plan on making him available for
questions making him available to the
public at any point we feel that dr
o'connor's statements and his detailed
report
again on a on a
on a situation as the as the doctor just
said is mild very mild and he's able to
continue to do his work is enough we
have dr zha here who's a medical doctor
who is who is renowned in this field uh
for kovid who is uh for the coveted
response and what we've been seeing for
the last 22 months 21 months
and so we wanted to make sure we
provided that expertise and that's what
we're doing and again dr uh dr o'connor
is providing detailed information uh on
on the president's physical health at
this time we appreciate the letter you
know you don't think there would be uh
additional value even just for assuring
the public and giving the press the
opportunity to ask your follow-up
questions directly no i hear we are
assuring the public we've been here now
i don't know 45 minutes talking to all
of you we were here an hour talking to
all of you answering questions fielding
questions and to be quite honest you
know uh there's nothing
i don't we don't believe and dr o'connor
believed there's nothing more that he
could add to what's already in his
report uh and so again we're going to
keep that commitment in providing
information every day uh a detailed
detailed information from from dr
o'connor but we we've we've answered
this question many times so let's let's
give your other colleagues okay question
services uh uh record keeping is
obviously in the news particularly
around january 6. this is also a cyber
security agency as well
i know that i'm not asking a question
about specific allegations but does the
president think that a federal agency
should you know have a system that
purges texts including
around you know for employees that have
a sensitive job such as you know
protecting the former president of the
united states so of course we believe in
the following the the public records
rules that is something that we uh
believe that should be done uh should be
followed uh and uh but i will i will say
this uh because this is i think
important the president has has
confidence in the men and women who
protect not just him but also his family
um you mentioned how the president is
feeling um better today but he still
sounded a little more hoarse during his
remarks is that at all any sort of cause
of concern or is that just kind of
you know
i don't know if any of you've ever had a
cold or a viral syndrome
i find that when i've had it in the past
sometimes i start feeling better but my
voice sounds a little bit raspier i
think that's what you heard today he
look when we spoke to him he was
energetic he's got a pretty packed
schedule um he's clearly feeling better
he says he's feeling better
um and he's got this cough and what
happens when you get cough is like after
a while your throat can get a little bit
uh your voice can get a little bit
hoarse and i suspect that's what's going
on here i just have one more clarifying
question on um the president's
temperature last night was it taken
as part of routine or was it take it
because of some discomfort as you had
mentioned earlier no it's just taking
part of his routine vitals
thanks karine this can be for either of
you or both of you in the conversations
that you've had with the president has
he expressed any regrets about the
recent mitigation or protocols he's
taken in the last
two weeks say regrets about not wearing
a mask at some point or somewhere he
went that maybe why he got kobet has he
said anything like that you know the
president the president likes to
interact and engage with the american
public what you've seen the last couple
weeks the last several months
i would argue the last several years is
joe biden being joe biden
and the reason why he has done the work
that he has done since he walked into
this administration on making sure that
there is a comprehensive coveted
response making sure there's vaccines
making sure there's boosters
making sure there's plaque packs over it
so that people are getting the treatment
that the president is getting right now
currently is so that we can get back
back close to normal right we're getting
there
and and this is part of his job is to
interact uh with the public is interact
with everyday people so he does not
regret that
and let me just add um that exactly as
karen said uh
we've heard nothing uh to that effect
but it's actually really there's a
broader import important point which is
i i find
um partly because i've been so involved
and so identified with kovid right over
the last two years a lot of people call
me when they get a positive diagnosis
and they say i'm sorry i failed it's not
a failure there's not a moral failure
this is not a problem like look it's a
very contagious virus it's
it's widespread um
people
will get infected
we should be doing things as a country
we have a whole set of policies that we
recommend to try to keep infection
numbers down but the key is to try to
continue to protect people from serious
illness um that's what we've done with
the president that's what we have
available for every american and that's
i think the most important point one
more you've mentioned a couple times
today that the president has said he's
working eight hours a day obviously he
said he's sleeping and you didn't want
to call him this morning
can you just give us a little sense of
what else he's doing when he's not
working those eight hours when he's not
sleeping the first lady's not here right
now
what how else is he spending his time
what do you do i mean eight eight plus
eight plus hours is you know that is
pretty that is pretty busy for someone
who is uh who is uh you know
mild symptoms uh with a virus look you
know the president is always working he
can work from anywhere
no i i'm getting there i'm getting there
karen i'm getting i'm getting there i'm
getting there um and so look i asked him
if he watched uh the january 6 public
hearing he said he caught some of it so
that is something that you can
you can see that he was doing last night
um and
you know but he wakes up in the morning
and he gets to work it is as you know a
big job being the president of the
united states being the commander uh in
chief so he is doing everything that he
would have done if he was in the oval
office except right now he is in the the
white house residence so there's not
besides the fact that he is doing this
in in the residence there's not much
difference right he is working
those long hours uh trying to deliver
for the american public
to that question should the president
walk more
should he not rest now that he you know
during this time because i see the white
house is trying to show how you know the
president is working hard he's doing
great you know videos and but is it not
supposed to rest more right now
that's
something for you yeah i mean i i think
in general it it's good for people to
rest when they get infections but the
bottom line is this president has a big
agenda and uh he has a lot that he wants
to do and he's he's he sets his schedule
of work
um
you know as i said here yesterday i
think it's important when people get
sick as a broader policy matter i think
it's important as a physician for people
to get rest people to get time off
but the president right now feels well
enough to continue working
uh and he has continued to work uh at a
brisk pace
and um you know as a as a physician i
will always encourage people to get more
rest
um but the president is is doing the
work of the american people
on the u.s africa
summit that the president announced this
week can you talk a little bit about
that how many coming people who invited
and what's the process of selecting
people will human rights
play a a key role and if if yes you know
how do you contrast that to the
president trip to saudi arabia so i'll
say this the president is very much
looking forward to meeting with african
leaders who will be here at the end of
this year uh and this there's a there
there's a lot of
a lot to discuss there will be a lot on
the agenda
and it is going to be his first time
meeting with leaders we will have more
to share
i don't have more uh details to share at
this time on who was invited and the
process
and what's going to be on the
on the agenda as you imagine there's
still a few more months
before we get there and so we'll we'll
be happy to to share more and have
background calls and provide all the
details uh to that once we get closer
okay
dr job to follow up on nancy's question
what is a normal blood oxygen level for
someone of the president's age and that
have passed history and sometimes has to
use i'm an inhaler
so age is not a determinant of oxygen
level
and somebody who's had a past history of
asthma or occasionally has reactive
airway disease also should not be a
determinant of oxygen level um i have to
tell you i can remember off the top i
had what the cdc defines uh as the exact
normal range it's in the 90s
um but i'd have to just sort of look up
but his has been consistently in the
normal range
um would you would you guys commit to
having the doc dr o'connor put in some
of these vitals so that we can you know
stop asking professor you guys with
those questions we appreciate the you
know the daily letter but especially his
oxygen level someone who had kobe twice
i know how important that is that is
going to be something up to the doctor
uh and and the president i can't make i
can't
i can't make any commitments on that
again we believe we have been providing
detailed information on we remember the
president is having very mild symptoms
the president is feeling better he is
improving
we are giving more information on a
president that has that's having very
mild symptoms than any other president
uh we are being as uh as uh transparent
as we as we are here today and i'm gonna
we're gonna take like one more question
because we have been standing here for
about an hour
taking and fielding questions
and
and you're going to continue to hear
from dr o'connor
via his letter we're going to take one
last question
one on the economy if you don't mind
next week's a very big week for the
economy so i read the cea blog is the
white house trying to change the common
definition of a recession because next
thursday the gdp numbers coming out are
going to show that we've been in
recession so let me say this you know
the strength of our labor market along
with the other economic uh factors is
what what we generally see in a
recession or even a pre a pre what
is not what we generally see in a
recession or even a pre-recession
because we're seeing the strength of the
economy and the labor market so that's
really important to note that there
because those are key elements as we
talk about that as folks keep asking us
about that so americans across the
country are back to work
at a historic level 21 states the most
in history have unemployed rates
unemployment rates at or below 3 percent
that is an important number to note 14
states
are now at their lowest unemployment
rates since this series began in 1976
and last month the unemployment rate was
a new low in eighth state so again the
strength of our labor market along with
the economic indicators is not what we
generally see
as we talk about a recession or even
pre-recession
the job for the three-month trend the
growth of job growth in the u.s is
shrinking it's decreasing and 7.5
million people a growing number are
multi-jobs meaning they have to work
more than one job to afford a living so
is jobs really a good indicator
look here's what i would say we've
always talked about the strength of our
economy we've always started talked
about how historic it's been and we've
always talked about the transitioning
right the transitioning to more stable
uh and steady growth and so to your
point about uh the job growth there this
is what we have been kind of stating for
the past uh several months look you know
the economy created 1.1 million jobs in
the second quarter
and so and around 375 jobs per month
those are historic numbers
those are if you think about the the 1.1
million jobs we are back to where we
were
at pre-pandemic levels so that is what
we see as strength of the economy again
we're going to transition into a more
stable
and steady growth and and so we're going
to continue the work that the president
has set out to do to make sure that we
continue to deliver for the american
people when it comes to the economy all
right folks thank you so much
just one more on the president
thank you everybody